I give the White House reporters in
particular this presidency a huge amount
of credit for doing an extremely
difficult job under difficult
circumstances I'm Kent Zimmerman I'm a
principal with the management consulting
firms like hazard group I am a
recovering lawyer that's thank you very
much let's take a look at some white
house correspondents asking president
Trump questions where it's not so easy
to get an answer and let's see whether
there are things to be learned from how
courtroom lawyers handle hostile
witnesses the president said that his
power over States was total absolute she
said that's not true who told you that
that was very effective but frequently
the facts are not used enough their gaps
term nearly 200 dead 14,000 you're sick
millions as you witness who are scared
right now what do you say to America who
are watching you right now you're scared
I say that you're a terrible reporter
that's what I say that's not responsive
to the question certainly a judge would
say to a witness that's not responsive
please answer the question certainly is
an option to say is there a reason
you're not answering the question do you
have an answer to the question and keep
them focused on answering to the extent
there are other people you saw dr. Burks
you saw vice president Pence behind him
certainly could say mr. president you're
not answering the question
vice president Panch are you able to
answer the question of dr. Burks are you
able to answer the question that would
be the closest I think that a reporter
could come to try to appeal to somebody
else you've said repeatedly that you
think that some of the equipment that
governors are requesting they don't
actually need you said New York might
need might not need 30,000 you said it
on Sean Hannity's Fox News he said you
know I don't you think you said was
correct
you act in a little more positive it's
always trying to make a question to you
how did you get you and you know what
that's why nobody trusts the media
anymore my house that gonna isn't hear
me that's why you used to work for The
Times and now you work for somebody else
first of all she's a fabulous journalist
and very talented one thing is rather
than saying you said on Hannity and then
characterizing what he said and then
Trump says no I didn't and denies a
slight change could be on Hannity on
this date you said quote and quote a
sentence or two to him use the exact
quote which is what would happen in a
courtroom rather than characterizing
what was said a little more likely to
pin him down although certainly not easy
to give her this president what do you
say to Americans who are upset with you
over the way you downplayed this crisis
over the last couple of months we have
it very much under control in this
country the corona virus is very much
under control in the USA it's going to
disappear it's like a miracle it will
disappear March 4th we have a very small
number of people in this country
infected March 10th we're prepared we're
doing a great job with it it will go
away it will go away you know it you
know it is going away and it will go
away and we're gonna have a great
victory and it's people like you and CNN
that say things like that that it's why
people just don't want to listen to CN
anymore and instead of asking a nasty
snarky question like that you should ask
a real question and other than that I'm
gonna go to somebody else the only thing
I might have done differently is after
he went into the why can't you yet ask a
nice question I would just say third do
you believe it's your job to tell
reporters what questions they should be
asking you I might also ask sir do you
believe that if you don't like the
question you don't have to answer it I'm
not sure there's much more that could be
done beyond that I think all that
reporters could do is point out when
what he's saying is false which many
reporters do Jim Acosta has done that
many others have done that yeah on
January 30
your travel ban a lot a lot and in fact
we'll give you a list what we did in
fact part of it was up there we did a
lot you know you're a fake
you know that your whole network the way
you cover it is fake and most of it and
not all of you but the people of wise to
you that's why you have a lower a lower
approval rating than you've ever had
before times probably three I thought
you did a nice job
could she have tried anything else
couple possibilities one is rather than
an open-ended what did you do in
February she could say sir can you name
the top two most important things you
did in February to protect the nation
from the coming Panda nailing him down
I'm answering let me ask you this why
did invitin why did why did Biden
apologize why did he write a letter of
apology and then second when he went out
and started talking about Vice President
Biden which was a diversion she instead
of saying nobody cares about by admin
and that's of course a debatable point
she could just say sir you didn't answer
the question attempting to move away
from questions that could be debatable
for questions that you could divert from
or deflect or serve you're not answering
the question please answer the question
why did you wait so long who you at one
clue and why did you not have social
distancing until March 16th we would i'm
wheat jajang with CBS News so if you
look at what I did in terms of cutting
off or banning China from coming in by
the way Americans who are also nice a
nation
just relax we cut it off you know when
he says to order asking a very
reasonable question using fax take it
easy
nice and easy those are part of me that
which is somebody would say why are you
talking to take a nice easy I'm asking
you a question
keep your voice down please keep your
voice down
did you know how many how many so
ironically when Trump tried to turn that
around and ask how many cases were hear
of the reporter that actually is would
be a good tactic to use on him to ask
very specific pointed questions how many
tell us your top to tell us the date you
did this those things more difficult to
deflect him when he does easier to say
you're not answering the question the
tactic that would be good to use on him
with trial errs would use to try to pin
down some of these actually answer a
question truthfully let's do one more
please in the back more Americans over
the course of six weeks and died in the
entirety of the Vietnam
deserve to be reelected so yeah we've
lost a lot of people but if you look at
what original projections were 2.2
million
we're probably heading to 60,000 70,000
far too many one person is too many for
this and I think we've made a lot of
really good decisions so it was very
effective she asked a hard question she
didn't get yes or no but she did get an
answer
remember that press conference was not
long after he embarrassed himself by
suggesting that perhaps people should be
drinking poison to cure themselves of
the corona virus that caused him to get
extensive criticism now he tried to make
it self congratulatory he did answer he
answered the question and I give her a
lot of credit for the way she asked it
it was short concise called for yes or
no cited data and I thought it was
effective great journalists are looking
to the truth I think they'd performed
extremely well under the circumstances I
think we owe the press great deal and
should be very thankful for the work
they do under our conditions every day
to try to hold public officials
accountable to get them to tell the
truth even when they deflect even when
they lie this president belittles men he
belittles women particularly wouldn't it
of color gives those reports those
journalists a world of credit for
maintaining their professionalism for
doing their very best to hold him
accountable for asking serious questions
[Music]